how's everyone doing who would have
thought that
the subject of hyperphysicality would be
so
relevant because we're having to
socially distance
but i actually feel socially closer
to more people i'm closer to you now
because i don't know if
that's your kitchen you'd have never
shown me your kitchen if we
were meeting now in boston together
[Music]
students usually embark on a large-scale
building exercise
where they build pavilions that are 15
feet or more in dimension
it's been i think a little bit difficult
because in the middle of this project
everyone had to leave campus go to their
individual homes
and sort of find what they could produce
essentially in their kitchens
when we originally set this theme of
hyperphysicality the context was
completely different
the world was okay and i think
thomas and i we're looking forward to
meeting you all in person
and having physical engaging discussions
about hyperphysicality
and then the world changed the students
are looking at physical means of
connection that are able to bridge
between
their various environments expanding
beyond that initial definition of hyper
whether that's through
light sound touch smell
orientation or movement
we've been interested in how you make
places engage people more our
research in our studio is how do you
bring people together
why would you go somewhere when you
don't need to
unless it really connects with your
humanity
in some way and engages you
i took hyper physicality to mean
creating
some sort of shared experience we had to
find a way
to merge the physical
and digital world it was very vague but
it became very interesting
because of this whole coronavare
situation
the students jumped in and
embraced the sudden shift in the
in the whole project and yet it was so
relevant
and it was a treat for us to watch
process happen over a number of weeks
so this is a giant tessellating
structure that would act as an acoustic
sound drop
an acoustic backdrop is hyper physical
because
it creates a more immersive experience
my project was basically trying to
create some sort of object that you
could
take into a video call in order to make
that call a more playful environment and
to sort of
have time with your friends that was not
limited to just this
box that we're in all the time now
our group wanted to focus on obsessive
rituals in particular
in light of this kobe 19 situation hand
washing
and we saw it as hyper physical because
soap
is one of the only things that we can
all physically touch right now and kind
of share
so you can see all of these five blocks
that we've been using for about
three weeks now when we wash our hands
and you can see how over time each
person has eroded
to emphasize different motions it's a
lovely project
i i love the materials you've used i
find them still
holding back a little bit in in terms of
form
i would push it to its limit until they
are
the definitive hand sculptural the dance
i mean there's a choreography
that you've really tracked which was
lovely
um and how you can they provoke that
that hand dance i think it's
really powerful to have people
involved in classes that are doing what
you want
to do when you graduate see kind of
what you're going towards
i really appreciate the amount of
efforts and deep thinking
that each of you have put into this
because i know it's an incredibly
abstract
brief dissecting the word hyper and turn
it into
these incredibly physical things that
yet
operate in totally non-physical ways in
order to connect you
there wouldn't have been a better time
to be thinking about this idea of hyper
physicality than
when you're at home trying to share your
experience with other people
that aren't there with you so you have
to find creative ways to express
yourself and that was
what this class was about i'm glad that
all of you were able to
sort of take i think the brief not just
as
something to design for but as a
methodology as well
that gave you physical interactions that
forced you to do physical things i feel
like i got to focus
more on building the narrative and
communication
in the studio i might have focused more
on
the tools seeing what i could do with
the tools rather than what the tools
could do
for me the wartime spirit
was quite amazing because every
student was working at home there was
the immediacy of what do you have around
your house
maybe we had a more meaningful
interaction in some strange way by not
being together
because we were thrown together in the
adversity
of the situation
[Music]
[Music]
you